hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action un leaches yesterday we won
a very nice game even though our
opponent blundered his Queen We were
already winning at that point but now
let's uh create another one uh so 10
minutes per player 0 seconds increment
Let's uh check it out and I think we got
the white pieces for the last two games
so probably we get the black pieces now
and our opponent is let's just uh leave
Zen mode is mod mod Hutson uh and we
already played him once we defeated him
so will probably be looking for revenge
and we will continue uh to go for the
Sicilian Defense and he had he goes for
the immediate D4 all right let's see
what he had in mind okay so he goes for
a pawn sacrifice and it's always polite
to to accept the pawn sacrifice and see
what our opponent had in mind so now we
can't really uh play the usual stuff as
he is ahead in development so we will
have to figure out how to go about
this uh so let's uh uh night F6 now will
be met with the immediate E5 so we
cannot go for that so how do we how do
we how do we continue
this uh yeah let's go for
E6 E6 and see uh how how to develop
probably some Bishop to B4 action maybe
even Bishop to to C5 but no Bishop to B4
makes sense but we're going to develop
the Knight first as I'm not familiar
with this particular set of moves uh so
we're going to do it this way all right
so now we can go for Bishop to
B4 uh sort of uh sort of developing but
not really yeah and we're going to go
Knight here so sort of to prepare D5
okay he goes for this we're going to
Castle and next we move our Queen and
we're looking for for D5 okay
now now it's starting to get very very
interesting all right so how do we how
do we get the most out of the position
we don't want our Pawn to be stuck here
after he plays E5 so can we can we do it
somehow if we if we capture and play D5
what's what's his plan like captures
captures this is fine the bishop is
attacking I play Bishop to B5 and put
some pressure on my knight here also
this Knight will have some issues but
uh yeah I don't know uh I'm going to ask
him to show show me why it's so so great
let's go
D5 why is this so
impressive yeah now depending on what he
does okay so he goes uh he goes
there we're going to
play we're going to go Queen E5
now if we go Queen e E5 he actually has
this capturing move and then we capture
sort of queen queen queen A5 he captures
we
capture ah if he goes for the Knight
yeah he can go for that we can capture
and we're still defending our Pawn he
he's going to capture with the queen and
then we take the bishop here with the
queen on E7 yeah looks looks okay okay
show
me show me why this is so impressive
let's go
here okay so he goes uh he he moves the
bishop as as he should and
now how do we how do we play this we
have some sort of an F6 move here it
looks ugly but if we can do it we should
do
it nah I don't want to play F6 just yet
let's go let's just move our Knight yeah
let's move our Knight
Knight if he captures we really don't
mind and now we've uh we sort of uh took
care of everything we're up a pawn okay
so he he's really going for attack and
he played H4 he wants to play H5 kick
away my
knight so how do we do this yeah we're
going to go Bishop to G4 uh simply to
pin the Knight and to free up the E5
Square for our Knight if he attacks it
with
H5
and then uh if he if he's really
persistent we're going to take the other
Pawn as well although first I would
really like to finish development like
play Rook E8 Rook d8 uh and then see see
what's
what uh but yeah it's a fairly standard
when someone uh goes for a line like
this that offers a pawn straight out of
the opening you have you will be down in
development but if you if you develop
precisely you should be able to to pull
it off and he might might have some
sacrifices here like H5 Knight goes here
I'm not seeing any Bishop
captures on H7 action because yeah like
if he had something like maybe Queen to
E4 maybe to connect with the Knights it
would be possible but my my Pawn here is
doing a fine
job yeah okay so he wants to play H5 and
he wants to threaten the H7 Pawn so
that's uh his plan and he's even betting
that this is not an
option so what all right let's do
it I'm kind of I kind of I'm not buying
this
so yeah okay uh even if he takes on H7
it's not like it's the end of the
world
yeah I'm even considering a move like
like this sort of stopping
H5
uh yeah let's do it or or do we get the
Rooks into the game first no I think
this is uh stopping H5 is the way to go
he might play
F4 but no he has to deal with this first
he can't give up another pawn and if I
trade my Queens I'm just up uh up
material so I I don't think that's an
option for him there's always a chance
he blunders with H5 because uh uh the
queen is on the other side of the board
and sometimes people forget about that
but here it's sort of Fairly obvious so
I'm not I'm not
hoping now he will capture first and
then he wants to take the pawn okay so
he he wins his Pawn
back uh but his King site is ruined so
I'm not really not really a fan yeah
okay fair
enough fair enough and
now
yeah okay so we don't have
this but we do have Rook C8 so let's
just put uh The Rook in front of his
Queen and we have one more Rook to
develop before deciding on any maybe
Queen A3 or maybe Queen to F5 we're
going to get our Queen into the game
somehow yeah okay so he avoids
discoveries and now he goes after the B7
Pawn
um stops any F6
action so how do we how do we deal with
this what's the cleanest
way yeah let's get the queen to F5
first if he captures here it's fine we
can just capture here and defend and
everything also we will have access to
G4 so he will not be giving up that
point he'll probably play some like King
to G2 and then we're going
to then we're going to figure out how to
go about
this although it's not easy finding
moves
here yeah probably something like maybe
even Knight to E8 with Knight E6 but as
as soon as I play this he's going to
advance the
pawn and I want him to advance the pawn
while my knight on C6 to have access to
E5 to put more pressure on
F3 yeah he's going to play King G2 like
we've uh talked about and now probably
probably just B6 yeah I'm I'm going to
play B6 and I'm going to ask him to
figure out what he wants to
play so I'm not saying my position is
winning but the ruined King side could
give me long-term Advantage like imagine
if we took everything off the board like
if we remove the Queens the Rooks and
Knight and the bishop the the pawn end
game will be superior and we will have
many many PA Pawn Islands to attack so
uh he can't really afford to trade it
down which
uh all right so what is what is Knight
captures is this a move now did he just
blunder because if he captures I take
the
queen and then he captures here I take
here and he delivers Checkmate yeah that
would be that would be very sad yeah
captures he has a check I captur the
Queen yeah he captures here King has no
I don't have to capture with the King to
allow Checkmate I can actually play King
to H7 uh but then I've given up
everything for the queen and it's
actually not worth it
so it's actually not worth
it is there something in between that
I'm missing
yeah not really not
really yeah that's actually not bad I'm
going to play King to H7 sort of to get
out of this mess and to have F6
ready now he's if he plays D5 I'm
actually not worried about that yes he
does have the past pawn and the d8
square defended but now I can actually
play
F6 uh to to reclaim control over the d8
square and now we are threatening to
capture here because then if he captures
we capture the queen he captures the
rook and then we get our Knight back
into the game okay so Bishop back to E3
of course uh he has to defend it and now
we have to figure out how to get back
into the game but now we can actually
just uh throw in a rook
d8 and uh we have to be careful where we
move our Queen uh since the F7 Pawn Now
isn't
guarded uh but yeah we want our Knight
on F5 now we can actually uh offer some
trades like we we go Knight E7 we move
the queen we put the Knight on F5 where
it will be very strong trading Rooks
should be okay for us uh at at any
point uh but we have to do it uh
according like if we move the Knight we
sort of weaken this Pawn so he might
have some attacks against this Pawn so
we'll see what happens and if he
advances the pawn like I said Knight E5
is always always a nice
move since the bishop on E3 also
prevents the queen from defending this
yeah okay so he wants to go for a queen
trade
now
um do we want to trade Queens here no
let's blockate the position first let's
blockate the position first
first get our Knight to a nice solid
Square okay so he goes for this I don't
mind trading now now okay so Knight here
yeah that would blunder the
Knight
um yeah let's go let's go like this H
let's go like this
oh we we we're happy with the end game
we didn't get uh any okay so he he
doesn't want uh he doesn't want uh call
it a day just
yet okay but now now let's just trade
let's just trade and we're happy with
that we trade we move the queen and we
get the Knight here that's that's how
we'll do it yeah Rook
captures uh okay so he goes after the
knight uh we don't mind
that H we don't mind that let's go here
with the Knight and if he plays H5 uh we
can just uh yeah he might even play H5
here yeah that's actually very
interesting but I'm still liking my
position much more yeah if he goes here
we're just going to go back with the
queen so we're not worried about this
we're actually happy that he
uh uh okay Rook H1 is a move but uh we
can we can just capture shouldn't be a
problem yeah should not be a
problem let's go here with the
Knight and now once we get our Rook into
the game with something like Rook to C6
we also have to control the past Pawn
okay he is much better on time but uh I
don't think he will be able
to to do all that
much okay so he goes after it as he
should huh let's go let's go like this
let's go like
this yeah now let's go like
this yeah he was he was uh he was able
to to trade down into a a pawn up end
game which is absolutely
amazing yeah let's go after that
pawn yeah okay so we're going to have to
defend the pawn down end game which is
sad but what are you going to do we it
has to be
done yeah okay you can do
that we're going to go here sort of
prevent him from going after my
Pawn Yeah could have uh could have
played this a little bit
better uh we can't trade Rooks since
we're down a pawn so that's uh not not
the
best so we need to win at least one more
Pawn before we before we decide on
anything yeah let's go
here yeah now he's better on time that's
uh not not what we wanted here okay so
he goes uh in uh with the King which is
the correct way to do it we're going to
play
this now we also get a pass Pawn but his
pass Pawn is much stronger okay so let's
go we have to push now it's uh now it's
already danger territory let's go
here yeah we have to
defend uh we're going to stop his Rook
from controlling this
Pawn
yeah okay he he has to go back with the
Rook uh he has to go back with the Rook
but he's still winning this yeah yeah
just this uh should should ensure him to
win no he's going to go for this
what why why would you do that
why would you do
that um is there is there a win here of
course there is but we just have to find
it and now we
okay yeah he has to play that now let's
go with the pawn go with the pawn go
with the pawn yeah I don't know I don't
know how he missed this
uh yeah very very interesting he will
play Rook here and then I'm just going
to advance my Pawn no he won't all right
so I have no idea what happened here
maybe I missed
something yeah okay I have to go back
obviously sorry about
that sorry about
that uh he might try to flag me but 17
seconds is uh more than more than enough
here yeah let's bring a Queen into the
game we can even bring another
one yeah it's very interesting I have no
idea what happened
here uh he he misplayed his position
immensely I misplayed my position
immensely first but then he out missplay
the the the position okay so we're going
to go here uh go for some checks
let's go here try to nicely connect with
the
Rook yeah let's go
here let's go
here okay I'm just going to move my king
so I can go for a nice checkmating
pattern
here
Seconds you will try to sacrifice The
Rook
um I'm playing without sound so usually
usually yeah okay so he will try to give
up The Rook here probably
no okay so yeah wasn't enough time he
was able to get a draw here wow yeah
it's very hard uh usually when I play
bullet or something I I I use the sound
to know when he made a move but here
when I'm recording this uh so you guys
don't have the double sound Echo I I
turn off the sound but yeah it's
obviously problem for me when I have a
little time on the clock but okay it's
not uh not why we are doing these videos
so let's see what we what we could have
done better here Knight F3 so it was a
it was a game of many misplays Bishop B4
okay so we actually played the opening
uh quite quite
nice captures captures D5 Queen A4 yeah
this is all perfectly fine uh Knight
here yeah Bishop G4 he went went for
this I captured E4 uh I see to E5 first
okay I thought about that but um I
thought the pawn can be easily defended
captures captures he captured yeah there
there's no reason to actually give back
the pawn he played this I played this he
played this yeah this is still fine Rook
fd8 Queen here yeah trading Queens here
is also fine uh but uh I'm interested
also in that position where he had
everything against my king yeah now he's
on like yeah okay this is still I
believe drawish
territory yeah okay z0 everything
fine uh I I I sacrificed the pawn here
for sort of to survive the attack he
traded everything and now it's okay he's
up a pawn it's a draw and then at that
one point where he should have gone for
that Rook move or maybe he did maybe I
miscalculated but we're going to see
what happened there okay this is all
still a draw draw draw draw draw okay
now now it's winning for him so so I
have to capture with the pawn for it to
be a draw oh of course because then you
also threaten this but yeah here now
he's
winning and uh yeah here was the moment
where he should have gone for this move
but he played
this yeah now he should have gone for
that but he played this and now I'm the
one that's winning but I did not have
enough time to do it uh I questioned
everything too
much uh and yeah that's always a problem
for me I mean there are so many ways you
can win this but I thought he would just
blunder a rook or something and then
when I it was down to like two two or
three seconds on the clock um I was very
hard uh so next time probably I will uh
include the sound just a little bit
maybe if I if I allow it to to play a
little bit louder then you guys will not
hear the double Echo uh but it will help
me if I get into time trouble like this
uh but yeah you've uh uh you've seen how
to how to handle the the C3 Sicilian you
know the the pawn sacrifice move and um
hopefully you will you will be able to
use it in your own games and then later
on you will uh play it much better than
I have and you will win many many games
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh if you have any
suggestions on what I should use for
other videos any any particular openings
I will try to try to figure it out um as
uh okay like I said I'm usually a
Scandinavian player here in these Rapid
Videos I'm playing the Sicilian but I
also don't mind I could even try playing
the D4 with white if you guys um uh
would like to see that but it's very
hard you know you guys ask me like how
to play against the Bon I played D4 I
have no idea what my opponent will play
so it's very hard to Target a certain
opening uh but yeah once again hope you
enjoyed it uh as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day